cyber security has become a growing
essential for any business leader with
recent studies more and more companies
are increasing their demand in equipping
their businesses with the skills to
respond to the fast growing risk of
cyber attacks
with more people working from home the
need for global connectivity and cloud
services is increasing which exposes the
risk that your organization can suffer
from data breaches relying on quick
cyber security solutions like an
anti-virus software or firewall no
longer works in this day and age and the
need to protect confidential information
is a pressing concern at the highest
levels of any business big or small
which is why udacity is excited to
introduce the cyber security for
business leaders program this program
will help equip future and current c
suites and senior managers from all
business functions with practical
knowledge skills and tools to prepare
for fast-growing cyber threats to their
digital ecosystem leaders will
understand the role of cyber security in
their business and set the stage for
their organization's specific response
plans this program will enable board
members who need to make high roi
investments on building systemic
approaches to mitigate the cyber
security risks implement the skills you
need to be cyber secure and keep
malicious actors from exploiting your
system start today by ensuring your data
stays protected by enrolling in
udacity's cyber security for business
leaders program